welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of secret
evasion episode 4 beloved which finally
gives us that steamy Cheeto shower scene
we've all been waiting for boom you
looking for this yup let's go through
this episode frame by frame for all the
details on the Scrolls spiricies you
missed and new rockstars is now three
channels this main channel for Easter
egg breakdowns the Deep dive for special
film analyzes and the break room where
you will find our secret Invasion after
show inside Marvel subscribe to all
three and support our network with a
skrull inspired shirt from nerd
riot.shop let's get started the episode
opens with Gaia where graphic left her
last episode and as I expected not dead
last episode we did see Gaia in that
fracking pod room passing Dr Rosa Dalton
which now we see her taking her memories
to know how to use the DNA to turn
herself into Super scroll and you can
see guys eyes and Cheeks getting flushed
with purple blood as she absorbs this
information what's interesting here is
that Gaia is getting this from the
humans memories think about it the human
doctor Dalton in that pod wouldn't know
how to do all this unless the process
was created before the squirrel assumed
her identity that means the whole super
scroll operation of harvesting DNA from
enhanced beans was a process created by
human scientists before the squirrels
hijacked it so what were the humans
working on before all this were these
aimed scientists trying to bring back
the extremist program weapons plus
scientists trying to make super soldiers
what are these damn humans doing but
remember there is a Charles Dalton who's
a member of the mi-13 in the Marvel
Comics government liaison between shield
and Aim so maybe the name Dalton was
specific for that reason a close-up of
gaia's screen shows extremists on the
far left and layered beneath it frost
beast and call obsidian which I take to
mean they're all just not selected here
as opposed to Gaia getting all of these
Powers but on the right side of that
screen we see the conditions of
extremists healing abilities and heat
strength so it's both the ability to
regrow tissue rapidly and spontaneously
generating fire which comes handy if you
get caught in explosion and Amelia Clark
like her Game of Thrones co-star Jon
Snow in season six we stay on our dead
body for a beat until Resurrection the
extremists the technology from Iron Man
3 heals the bullet wound and we hear the
the heartbeat I gotta point out how Gaia
immediately reverts back from her scroll
green skin to human upon waking up like
for someone who prefers home in her own
skin it's all most instinctual that
she'd be in human form whenever she's
alive and not even take a second to stay
in her scroll body okay moving on like
last episode we flashed back to a moment
in the past with Fury and Vara slash
Priscilla here it's 2012 in Paris right
after the battle of New York in the
first Avengers movie a newspaper reads
in French
which I guess translates to no we could
not come up with a better headlines so
we kept it literal as Fury walks in he
passes a black woman and has a moment
with her I know I don't think Fury is
confusing her for his wife but it does
show that Fury has a type and Vara was
right to pick the human form that she
did and the fact that Vara did this is
just not sitting right with me I'm gonna
get to it more in this analysis but we
see how Samuel L Jackson has been
de-aged again but this time just simply
back to his appearance in that 2012
movie maybe it's the warm lighting but
Jackson didn't have quite as thin and
smooth of a face in 2012. also the eye
patch clings a little too neatly to his
face this goatee seems to be a bit
thicker and look more glued on than
Jackson's natural hair did in 2012. yes
yes I'm nitpicking overall it looks
really great great it's just when you're
visually referencing one of the biggest
movies of all time an era the MCU
constantly revisits instead of daging
normally just suggesting hypothetical
youth in a character's life it's just
harder to fool us but I bring it up
because this orange lighting gives this
whole scene a fictitious nostalgic Rose
tinted glasses quality like Furious
recalling a romantic pass to Vara that
was never actually real Vara tells Fury
that after seeing the Battle of New York
and the formation of the Avengers she
assumed it must have been him who
brought them together think about it as
a scroll she would be especially
sensitive to a group of terrans and one
Asgardian beginning to build a suit of
arm around the world to ward off
extraterrestrial Invaders varus's Fury
has a quote powerful sense of
righteousness which reminds me of Jules
famous Pulp Fiction monologue about the
path of the righteous man as we said on
all sides by the iniquities of the
selfish and the tyranny of evil men
remember that Bible verse Ezekiel 25 17
is on Nick Fury's fake Tombstone from
Captain America Winter Soldier the
direct homage to Jules and Pulp Fiction
last week I pointed out how in 1998 Vara
was reading Raymond Carver's A New Path
to the waterfall and she talks about
Carver here how he's known for his
brevity but his poems pack a punch just
like Fury does but Mara has Fury read
from Carver's poem late fragment and did
you get
what you wanted from this life
even so
I did
and what did you want
to call myself beloved
feel myself beloved
on the Earth
so I put it out last episode that Carver
wrote this collection when he was dying
prematurely from lung cancer but his
life had turned around from a new
marriage with Tess Gallagher they were
only married for six weeks but in these
nine months Carver got what he wanted
from his life to feel beloved on this
Earth and we can view this as a romantic
statement but it's also another way of
saying home in my own skin Vara wants to
feel home on this Earth but it's also
another example of extraterrestrial
Scrolls valuing and needing human
scientific and cultural achievements
Vara cannot honestly tell Fury she loves
him so she has to use the words of a
human poet to do it back in the present
Vara meets scrotie then I'm now going to
call it scroll Roadie because it's not
Roadie but it is squirty they meet at
the Saint James Church that he told her
to meet him at last episode the choir
sings the song Deep River which is an
African-American spiritual popularized
by Henry Burley in his 1916 collection
but really written by Anonymous sources
because it was one of many songs that
was passed down by slaves and yeah it
feels pretty odd for a bunch of white
British Catholics to be singing a black
spiritual but I think that's the idea
especially considering
are Scrolls appropriating Black humans
with Varan even admitting to doing this
to appeal to Fury's type this is so
messed up but we should point out that
one of the most popular Renditions of
Deep River was by Paul Robeson in the
1940 film The Proud Valley we're calling
Sonia Paul's first likening of Nick Fury
with Paul Robeson in episode one but
here scrotie brags about firing Fury I
ddt'd that dude from the top rope
yeah it was like Undertaker level
interesting that this girl posting his
roadie would know her pro wrestling
references but also we're pretty sure
that the Undertaker never actually did a
top rope DDT his DDT was more of a
running variation where the Undertaker
did the DDT after sprinting toward the
opponent so in many ways squirty is a
poser squirty Winx and Vara may be a way
of indicating to her that he knows that
she's bugged and to put on a little
performance here for the eavesdropping
husband so we don't really know if Vara
means it when she says he's broken he's
been broken ever since he came back from
the blip or the old Fury the one with
power the one with ability the one who
was indispensable to us
that theory is gone so this new one
he'll be dead from exhaustion and defeat
soon enough this could be another
reference to the two Furies I speculated
about last episode like perhaps the
reason Fury who came back seems so
different it's just a scroll double
posing as Fury I get it it's a reach
Theory but you know we'll see you next
episode and scrotie warns you keep
telling me what you're not gonna do
I'm gonna show you what I am going to
yeah I got to give some credit to Don
Cheadle here he definitely plays this
episode with more of a feminine energy
or at least a delicacy that he didn't
really give off before Pagan tells
gravic it is a reason Gaia isn't here
with us she's the mole
I've already taken care of her yes sir
yeah remember the last time we saw Pagan
he was in human form on that submarine
where it seemed like that
British tried to turn the missile Keys
somehow he got out of that mess but now
he's realizing that graphic played him
like a pawn in order to out Gaia it's
probably not feeling great about it
graphic instructs the soldier remember
we want him to think it's the Russians
make it big loud like the Russians would
yes it's a sub graphic and the soldiers
later yelling in Russian during the
attack but I think it demonstrates a
misunderstanding about the Russians in
human nature yes Russian foreign policy
is often chest thumping but the KGB the
clandestine operations of the Russian
state are famously discreet they use
things like poisoned water bottles they
don't often take credit for things even
the militia they sent to occupy Crimea
did not wear Russian Flags or Russian
uniforms are claimed to be part of the
Russian military the only way we know
it's Russia is that our intelligence
Services link it back to Russia but it's
not like Russian assassinations are
trying to say hey it's the Russians we
did this so yeah I just think graphic
isn't that smart so Taylor's pitches guy
on his plan to shut down Graphics
Insurgency somehow with the three of
them then go to president Ritz and tell
him you're welcome and then get him to
declare anasty for 1 million Scrolls
never mind the legal Authority the
president would need for this or the
ability to do all of that while keeping
it a secret or the cost of it yeah both
Talos and graphic have shitty plans so
Gaia doesn't buy it want to live in your
own skin and by pushing this plan to get
to Ritz and later Talos will die slowly
dragged back into his own skin now the
bench they sit on has the name Carter on
it and the dates 1993 to 2000. I was
thinking maybe Peggy Carter but Peggy
was born long before 1933 she died way
after 2000 she died in 2014. so who
knows maybe it could be someone related
to her or the power broker is sponsoring
benches in London secret invasion is
great for when you've got the itch for
subtlety and subterfuge but when your
sense of fantasy leans more toward Epic
Fantasy war then you're gonna want magic
The Gatherings universe is beyond set
the Lord of the Rings Tales of Middle
Earth available now the Lord of the
Rings Tales of Middle Earth is an
absolutely epic introduction of your
favorite characters stories and settings
from the genre defining fantasy novels
directly into magic the gathering's
trading card game if you're somebody who
knows the Lord of the Rings books by
heart you're already a leg up on the
competition by knowing which characters
pair well together the mechanics of the
game and the lore of the books go hand
in hand and if you're like me and love
running what-if scenarios you can build
out your decks to set up showdowns
between Aragorn and Gandalf Sam wise and
Sauron whoever you want the Lord of the
Rings Tales of Middle Earth is the
biggest magic release so far this year
by highlighting iconic characters
stories and settings Magic the Gathering
offers a new and rewarding experience
for current and new players to enjoy to
get started with the Lord of the Rings
Tales of Middle Earth just click the
link in the description below zavara
comes home and sees Nick Fury's wedding
ring in the dish signaling to her that
he might know about her loyalty to
graphic does he know he knows you're in
danger girl now as Fury carries the tea
over you can see Vara discreetly pulling
the gun out of her bag and hiding it
under her leg now Fury clocks this a
moment later because he brings it up but
here it's easy to miss and this is the
gun that Vara got from the safety
deposit box it's an m p Model 9 the
pistol commonly used by Shield one of
Nick Fury's pistols so when they duel
later they are firing the same model gun
at each other whereas before Fury wore
his spy glasses while talking to Vara
now he doesn't bother he knows
everything he needs to know about her
and yes he probably caught Fury Brewing
that tea in a green Kettle as all their
cookware is scroll green Fury just comes
out with it of all the dumbass
wrong-headed Reckless
things I've done in my life you are
far Far and Away
the greatest mistake
I lost all my reason to be your husband
so doing some math here if Yuri and Vara
had been married for 12 years at this
point inferior was gone for five of
those years during the blip this would
be the Seven Year Itch Farah reveals
that she got this human form from a
doctor Priscilla Davis who had a
congenital heart defect and didn't want
her family to know but at some point
I had to acknowledge the truth of
what I was actually doing there in the
first place which was
looking for someone who would slip your
defenses oof so Vara disguised herself
as a medical worker I assume initially
looking for a dying black woman of a
certain age to use as a Nick Fury
Honeypot I don't think I have to go into
further detail on how messed up that is
but also the fact that Fury never
thought to ask this girl this question
shows us that their marriage was never
really On Solid Ground to begin with
communication's everything people Vara
says that the real Priscilla asked her
to keep three promises one to bury her
at Sea so did Bara have to like
personally cremate her and take the
ashes out on a cruise two to continue to
be a daughter to her parents and three
to never hurt Fury but just like Fury
broke his promise to the skrulls so too
did Vara to him and just because we look
at every name on the show Priscilla
Davis any connection to Aaron Davis
Donald Glover's character in the MCU I
don't think she has kids but maybe a
nephew now you probably knows throughout
the scene vara's mask art is prominently
displayed behind her on the wall
reflecting the many faces of Deceit worn
by this woman literally as a scroll and
metaphorically with her husband they
were turn to the Raymond Carver poem as
a kind of dual countdown and a goodbye
to their marriage as this poem was a
goodbye between Carver and his wife Tess
it was a dialogue gunshots fire and the
camera Cuts around the house and we see
a framed book cover with Priscilla's
face decoding the Superhuman Gene this
may have been the research that the
Daltons used to develop the enhanced DNA
harvesting technology that the squirrels
use for super Scrolls we also see a
sculpture that looks like a DNA sequence
next to it also in the scene on the
shelf behind Fury there is an AMA
Foundation Award for excellence in
medicine so posing as a human doctor it
seems like Vara continued her scientific
contributions to Human Society she was
really the opposite of the human
stereotype graphic raged against to the
scroll Council but in the shootout
biryanvara didn't actually shoot each
other just shot past each other Vara in
the wall post Fury and one of those
Stone masks on the wall which could be
his way of showing that even with one
eye he could still Bullseye someone
through the eye socket across the room
they end with this mutual agreement that
their marriage is over followed by a
quick postmortem question would you have
loved me if I'd never changed
if I'd been my true self
guess we'll never know yeah it's a
pretty Grim take on marriage right now
recalling Henrik Gibson's play a doll's
house or Gustav La Bear's Madame Bovary
both of which carry a theme that men
sometimes fall in love with the role
their spouses can play in their own
little doll's house while putting up
blinders to the inner worlds of their
wives and not really properly
communicate with them or know them and
we cut from the scene to what we assume
is Vara taking a cleansing shower
because we see a female squirrel
enjoying being in her own skin like it's
a Pantene commercial but no she wipes
the steam from the bathroom mirror and
it is scrotie I love the reveal on the
mirror wipe implying that it's a
decisive and begrudging switch back to
human form as opposed to a human body
this girl has gotten used to as seems to
be the case with Gaia the femininity of
this girl as she's taking a shower seems
to be a big deal here and this is the
first time we've seen a long-term sex
swap on the series I mean we did see
Taylor's briefly take a female form but
this is this girl's longtime human body
in the comics the male squirrel Pagan
took the form of the female Elektra now
in the credits this girl's name is rava
who in the comics is a squirrel pirate
who interacts with Blackpool give
outright villainy in this episode as she
pretends to be Roadie I wonder if rava
might be set up as an alternate villain
on this show someone who could play The
Scroll Queen varaki role from the comics
Furious surprises Roadie in his hotel
suite I wanted to share my favorite
liquid lunch with you Pepe van wenko
23 years of distilled Perfection oh my
God Pappy Van Winkle 23 is the same
brand of Whiskey from She-Hulk episode 2
the super expensive whiskey that Jen
Walter's boss Mr Holloway bought for her
at the bar and that bartender member
looked over at Jen to make sure she was
sure about this so Pappy Van Winkle a
very real and very expensive brand of
whiskey five to six thousand dollars a
bottle and we learned that in this
whiskey Fury put a liquid location
tracker and he actually even kind of
tells scrotie that he's doing this in
the scene making a nanobot joke now this
has me wondering if all Pappy Van
Winkles and the MCU have trackers in
them and Jen got boozed up in a similar
plot by the intelligencia to steal her
blood I don't know I just think it's a
good new rule if you're in the MCU just
don't drink Pappy Van Winkle 23 at least
there's better ways to spend your money
but it's interesting how scrotie was
surprised because she was expecting Vara
to kill Fury but now that Fury's alive
scrotie knows that Bara couldn't go
through with it while scrotie does not
drink it first not trusting Fury Fury
plays low status he frames this meeting
is just wanting to get his job back
which fools Grody into lowering her
guard and drank in the Pappy now it's
interesting how the TV screensaver reads
welcome Mr Rhodes with this weird a
symbol I'm assuming this is for the
hotel that he's staying in you know
sometimes when you check into a room it
just has your name on the screen but
still I would think that the concierge
would know to call him Colonel Rhodes
and not Mr Rhodes skrody shows Fury the
footage of Graphics shooting Maria Hill
posing as Fury this is the one Maria
Hillside in this episode that got Kobe
Smulders a credit at the end of the
episode but even after Roadie stops
playing the footage notice how the sound
bar continues to fluctuate could just be
an error or it could indicate scrotie is
recording their current conversation as
well outside protesters yell at Colonel
Rhodes over the American conflict with
Russia and I like how One of the signs
says read sin instead of ritzen with our
ID underlined she said classic British
wit so president Ritz and arrives from
Air Force One and scrotie says there's a
full briefing for him inside Stagecoach
which is one of the nicknames for the
Beast which is the president's armored
Cadillac there's at least nine of these
we don't really know everything about
their construction but the name
Stagecoach comes from the 1939 John Ford
directed John Wayne starring Western
featuring a prolonged Chase and a
stagecoach the idea is no matter how
many Bandits come after trying to break
their way in nothing will I like how
scrotie's bodyguard poor guy wearing a
sling a call back to Fury twisting and
breaking his arm in the pub back in
episode two squirty weirds president of
Ritz and out by touching his arm and
quoting Vladimir Lenin not John Lennon
but the Soviet leader Vladimir saying
when you find flesh you push when you
find steel you stop he's referring to a
quote attributed to linen about probing
with bayonets and it's more commonly
known as when you find mush you push
either way Ritson smells this as Colonel
Rhodes pregaming with too much pappy23
and scrotie what a jerk still requires
the one-armed Aid to open the door for
them which the real James Rhodes would
never ever do so scrotie calls the other
squirrels to report that Citadel the
presidential code name for POTUS is in
the fourth car and the Scrolls fire
missiles from a helicopter customary
boom looking for this now for the US
presidential motorcade to not have clear
airspace in a friendly Nation would mean
that graphic must also have Scrolls
placed in the UK military while the
shootout goes down squirty just sits
peacefully in their armored car waiting
for it all to end one would think one of
those Secret Service agents would ask uh
War Machine Iron Patriot don't know what
your current name is but kojo suit up
and help please graphic and the other
Scrolls yell loudly and Rush In which
fools the Secret Service
no question I mean is that really your
job right now but Fury he fires an RPG
at the helicopter reminded us to that
awesome moment when he fired an RPG at a
jet taking off with nukes in 2012's The
Avengers but Graphics plan falls apart
pretty fast just by Fury being there so
he has to drop the Russian false flag
plan and out himself as a Super Squirrel
revealing his Groot arms I like how we
see the wood crack and Splinter around
the secret service agent yeah that guy
got pretty crushed so graphic now has
two super scroll Powers confirmed
extremists and Groot does he also have
call obsidian and frost BEAST's Powers
we'll find out Taylor struggles to punch
through that armored glass which would
be five inches thick and would stop a 44
magnum bullet he takes a shot causing
him to partially Revolt into scroll form
and looks really gnarly like the
scroll's skin comes back and strips and
ribbons like skin grafts slowly working
their way from the back of his head to
his face really seems like death in this
case is represented by green flesh and
purple blood Fury gets president Ritz in
his safety and he notices the British
soldier who nearly shot Taylor's before
is helping taylos now Fury knows that
since he told that Soldier to f off and
leave Taylor to him this guy cannot be
trusted and must be gravic so Fury
shoots a soldier and the reversion to
grab it gives us interesting purple glow
that we haven't seen before this could
be the scroll skins and body armor that
they wear part of the scroll technology
for their clothes that follows their DNA
transitions Graphics stabs tails in the
heart looking into Taylor's scroll eyes
as he watches him die Fury shoots
graphic in the chest and then in the
face whoa ouch bfxr has added some crazy
detail some daylight through the Bullet
Hole to show the exit wound but also a
piece of Graphics ear ripped off so did
he turn that fast as the bullet would
curve through his face flesh and then as
it exited would slice through part of
his ear I mean I'm sorry to disapprooter
this but that is one magic Fury bullet
it's like curving the bullet and won it
but either way extremist heals it
graphic never even closes his eyes or
winces remember extremists that make you
pain resistant it just gives you rapid
healing and Theory as he had to leave
Maria hill behind now he has to leave
Taylor's behind losing allies by the
episode the episode ends similarly to
how it began instead of the daughter on
the ground now it's the father no
resurrections this time if my theory
from last episode is right that we may
be seeing two Furies and this could
actually be Soren Soren would have just
seen her husband die but assuming it's
just fury it's still another beloved
begone remember Gaia asked Talos if he
wanted to be home in his own skin for
Talos to be home is really to die and so
for Talos we'll close out with Raymond
Carter's words and did you get what you
wanted from this life even so I did and
what did she want to call myself beloved
to feel myself beloved on this Earth and
Taylor's you'll always be beloved to us
hey a huge thanks to Noah Chen Eric
Francisco Gina Polito and Jordan Morris
for their big help in writing this
breakdown subscribe to all three of our
channels and support us by grabbing some
merch at nerdright.shop follow me on all
social channels that eat a boss follow
me rockstars thanks for watching bye